Like a murderer from the past, like
Gingiss con or something like that. Well,
you actually get in trouble
now for cultural appropriation.
You know where you
wouldn't get in trouble.
Is that the renaissance fair when they
have like heroes and villains day goes on.
What you're doing there,
you got some squinty eyes.
I'm going out with tape too far. Right.
And then you're taking it too far,
isn't it?
But why is it weird that
a physical characteristic
like eyes like cl small eyes
is like offensive to discuss?
Is that fast? It is fascinating,
but I recreate I think.
Is it offensive or is it people
enjoy the feeling of being offended.
I think there's this, there's a
sweet spot in the middle of there.
I would beg to differ that some of the
people in society who are offended by
words,
terms,
sentences aren't necessarily
truly offended as much as
they want to say they're
offended. I am 100% on
board with you. So Lucy,
doctor Peluso. Sorry. All
right, thank you doctor Peluso.
I have an HPV HD Phi Abd.
I can't, I mean people get offended.
It's exhausted. They love it.
They love getting offended and you
know what? They also love doing,
not doing shit about it,
but in their defense,
if you see like a movie where
a dude is playing an Asian man,
but he's a white dude and they
do some malarkey with his eyes,
you're like mother fucker
working with his eyes.
What did he turn him into?
A leprechaun,
something Irish with
someone at Charlie Chan.
The fucking fucking all from use that
special effects Malarkey can change and
went to a Chinaman. Oh God
damn Leprechaun, that fucker.
You could be an Englishman.
No one has a problem with
calling someone an Englishman.
You call someone a Chinaman and no wall.
You're getting weird. They're weird.
It's exhausting when people are offended
and then it's like girls being offended
and writing articles about guys
that are doing me too moments,
but they're not going to the VA,
the rallies,
they're not involved in the community.
They're not really like moving
the needle there, just screaming.
Is it good to go to rallies?
I think it's good to be also actively
and physically involved in whatever
movement you believe in.
I think just saying it and
posting it on Twitter is a facade,
but it's good for likes. You can
get a lot of likes. Boom. I mean,
I guess there's some eyeballs on it.
You're, you're creating a conversation.
But I dunno, I just believe
in like living, walking
the talk a little bit more.
What the fuck are we just talking about?
The gang has con oh,
Chinese, um, actors that get fucked
out of roles by white people.
They don't do that anymore, but they
used to, but one of the big ones was, um,
Charlie Chan. Charlie Chan was
like a famous detective show.
Remember that show was,
it was it cast it as a white man?
It was a white dude playing,
uh,
a Chinese detective that was like
super wise detective that's busted,
but he looks like, you know, like a
white guy who eats good like math block.
More like a commish. No, like
that's, that's all right.
My Holy Hell. Yeah, that was Charles Chan.
I'm offended. Yeah, he should
be. He looks more like,
he looks like a shitty magician who
looks like chewy from the comedy store.
You don't,
you guys don't remember chewy that is
offensive at the same thing happened with,
um, let me see that picture. Look
at that. That shit is ridiculous.
[inaudible] happening there.
These,
he looks like he runs a casino and
upstate New York. You ever hear him talk?
Can we play? Some of them need
to hear it from Charlie Chan.
It was very offensive.
Oh my God. Don. Don,
let's listen to this. Charlie. I'm,
I'm shocked right now. So Jamie. Okay.
What do you think? What you hear? What
year do you think this was? 1945 it says,
say fifties scarlet
Johannson had that holy,
she remembers she was cast in that movie
and it was supposed to be an Asian role.
Yeah. And Holly and people went
crazy over it. Balle spelled,
let's hear some of this.
Here we go guys. I can't,
Alrighty. You have telephone. Wait
a minute. I got your telegram.
I started watching all train you contact
mysterious Mr Raj or pick him up and he
got off the train and Hodge. That's
one of my man over that. He and I have,
I owe him plus seven now rounds.
You know, you follow him.
He couldn't help it. I figured you heard
about partner on the ground. Right.
So we've kept totally,
what's his face?
He doesn't even look remotely.
They taped his eyes for sure.
They did some weirdness,
but not much because he looks like every
housewife in Bev hills minus the facial
hair. The pullback phase. Okay. Yeah.
Where you're like take off 10 years,
but back then you know this guy could
get away with that. You know? Uh,
what's his face? John Lady in the
Saran wrap. She's a ghost or some shit.
Dude. What's happening
to her? That is bizarre.
I mean not their hands around ran back
then. That could be just shit. Oh Shit.
Oh bubble wrap up.
Food is just get out to Tj's on things
budget and take it home after the party
balloon.
Put your food inside of it.
It's like your face.
What is that Shit Dude?
She's wearing like a glass veil
or something. Shiela booth.
Is that Louis Gomez and
Shiela booth. They're time
travelers. And this is, I mean,
isn't it great to live in this time where
our movies are so much better but are
going to laugh in the future? Looking
back at how stupid things are today,
you just can't see a comment. Number one.
You still have to re look at that guy.
That's a cool chair. What is that dude?
So another Chinese guy, that dude,
it's not really a Chinese guy.
Thank you God.
That's some terrible face
makeup I think added to them.
I think that looks like a,
like Joey Diaz on acid.
Look at that with a head wrap.
That's fancy tape.
It does look like Tate a regal
Tate older Tate on acid acid.
Real angering. Ruling a kingdom
after a couple of divorces. Yeah,
he's like an 80 year old Tate. Yeah,
that's, well that's what they used to do.
But look up John Wayne as Gangas con.
That's even dumber cause I didn't even,
I didn't even change anything,
including the way he talked.
He talked like John Wayne,
I'll go out there or you're
gonna fuck up these Russians.
He talked literally like John Wayne,
but he was dressed like
a for fucking hat on and
so dumb. Oh my God, you
got to see it. I'll see it.
When they made that movie where
they're like, this is it. This is it.
They didn't know everything sucked.
Everything did kind of suck for sure.
It's only a few like gone with the
wind, like, Whoa, what did they do?
There are a few movies, citizen
Kane like, whoa. You're like,
wow, this one doesn't
suck. I got lost there.
I up gang guess God.
I mean,
the likeness is a little lasing
a two weeks. Wow. Imagine,
look at that beard.
Who went from playing like a
fucking sheriff and some wild west,
wild west town to Gingiss Khan.
Hollywood was so whitewashed.
It really, really was. Well, they knew
back then, if they did a John Wayne movie,
they would sell a million tickets. You
know? That's really what the, what the,
the thing is. I mean, an
aspect of that still going on.